le collège auguste lacaussade est un
établissement flambant neuf et les
jeunes du cirque de salazie étudient ici
à mare à citrons
dans ce havre de paix à peine troublé
par l'écho des cascades et le chant des
oiseaux
la poésie des lieux rappelle t-elle le
souvenir d'auguste lacaussade
est ce que vous savez qu'ils étaient
auguste lacaussade
non c'est réunionnais dont les
réunionnais d'aujourd'hui peuvent être
très fiers de ça sinon un navigateur ou
un aviateur mettrais d'être mieux connu
pour les salaziens en particulier et
c'est un poète qui a vécu autant que
m'en souvienne au 19e siècle dans
l'ancien collège avait une plaque
commémorative où il y avait un monceau
de son de taxes qui l'avait fait quoi
mais avant d'être un poète c'est un
métis ce collège auguste lacaussade
n'aurais pas pu le fréquenter de son
temps tout simplement parce qu'il est né
en 1815 d'un père avocat et d'une mère a
franchi deux couleurs et être mulâtre
interdisait alors l'accès aux études
c'est pourquoi ses parents l'envoient à
nantes
après des études brillantes le jeune
homme revient au pays
révolté par les préjugés raciaux il n'y
reste pas c'est anvers qu'auguste va dès
lors exprimer sa révolte
la revue de paris les salazienne en 1839
sa poésie plett lui par deux fois il
obtient le prix bourdin de l'académie
française
très doué en langues il traduit aussi
des oeuvres anglaise polonaise et
italiennes à la mort de sa soeur en 1840
il revient à bourbon une nouvelle
déception
il rentre en france où il milite avec
victor schoelcher pour l'abolition de
l'esclavagé l'esclavagé aboli la
caussade poursuit son combat politique
et quand le conseil général de la
réunion lui alloue une pension il le
prend comme une offense il est déjà
décoré de la légion d'honneur en 1872 il
est nommé bibliothécaire au sénat
il meurt à paris à 82 ans